Hey, give me a sec.
I'm not alive right now.
Jokey Bird needs 1-2 hours to be a person again.
I woke up 15 minutes ago, so I'm not real at the moment.
I'm not real.
Oh my god.
I slept, I don't know, I think I slept too much.
I was in a dream within a dream.
And that was like the worst type of dreams to have.
Because like, um, okay, it was a, it was a fucking freaky movie.
Like, it was a fucking scary movie dream too.
Um, because it was like, I basically like, um, it was like a horror film.
So like my dream within a dream, um, was basically I woke up, and then my door had this like little, like little, like, entraption on the door.
Where it was closing by itself.
And was trying to lock me in, and I was like freaking out about it.
And I was like, what the fuck?
Like, why am I being locked in?
Who's here?
And then I forced open the door.
Yeah, I got in a nightmare.
And then I heard some noises in the bathroom.
And I tried to peek in.
And then like, um, and then there was some random guy in my bathroom.
And was like, don't come in.
And I was like, what the fuck?
I was like, who are you?
And then I looked, and then I forced myself in.
And then I just see this bloody guy in my bathroom, in the bathtub.
And I was like freaking out.
And I was like, holy fuck, what the fuck?
And then I woke up.
But I wasn't fully awake yet.
Like, I wasn't, I was still in my dream.
Like, I woke up, but I was in, why are you trying to enter?
Because I was in a horror film, and people in horror films don't make fucking right decisions.
Like, I had to play my part.
I...
Anyways.
And then, um, and I woke up.
We're in.
I'm so self-aware.
I don't break meta.
Anyway, so, um.
So, I woke up, I was still in my dream.
And then the craziest part was that...
First thing I do was open Discord in my dream.
I was like, oh my god, I had a crazy dream.
Like, I don't know, I messaged somebody.
I don't remember who I messaged.
I was like, oh my god, I had the craziest dream.
Like, there was a fucking man in my bathtub with blood all over him.
I think he was like, murdered somebody?
And then, like, I don't remember the conversation.
I was just, like, being like...
And then the person was like, oh, you mean that...
Wait, we saw...
Like, you mean, like, when we were, like...
When, like, we met up and saw, like, that creepy man?
And, like, that was following us around?
And I was like, we met up?
I was like, what?
Where did I see her?
I'm so confused.
I was like, what?
Where did I...
And then, like...
And then I was so confused.
I was like, I don't remember ever meeting you.
And then we saw...
We saw somebody following us.
And then I had a dream flashback.
I...
Of, like, for some reason, I had...
A dream flashback where it showed me and her and the guy following us.
And I was like, what the...
I was like, what the fu...
My dream punch scene of this guy.
And then I was like, oh my god, you're right.
He was following us.
Like...
You be dreaming of a time movie.
Apparently so.
And then, I don't know.
And then I woke up.
And then I had a nut different dream.
And then, I don't know.
I don't remember after that.
That was, like, the craziest shit.
Cause I, like, it was so vivid.
Like, I remember that part.
But I don't remember the other dreams I had last night.
I slept a long time.
I went to bed early.
And I went to bed early.
And then I woke up literally 15 minutes ago.
But yes, that was my dream today.
There's not much to update you guys about today.
Because, yes, last night and today was really boring.
Cause all I did was mostly sleep after the stream.
So, I mean, I did work stuff.
And then I went to bed.
How's Doki Amber Doge?
He's also sleeping right now.
But yeah, today is another part.
I don't know if I'm doing a super long...
It depends on how my voice is feeling throughout the day.
So, like, I don't know if it's going to be a super long Dynasty Warriors stream.
Or if my voice is going to give up, like, a bit after.
So, I'm going to stop at a point where I feel like I need to rest my voice.
So, today is another part of Dynasty Warriors.
I have no idea how much more we have.
I asked my thumbnail maker to make, like, three Dynasty Warriors thumbnails in advance every time.
So, like, cause I feel like it's going to be a lot.
I feel like three months is going to pass.
And then you're going to tune into the channel and you'll be like, Is she still streaming Dynasty Warriors?
Yes, we are not done yet.
We're not done yet, guys.
Alright, so let's get to it.
Cause I'm doing everything too.
I don't know, I've been enjoying it a lot.
I know it's not, like, the most popular playthrough.
But who the fuck cares?
I like it.
I get one, okay?
One a year where I play a game that I just enjoy.
I'm broke.
Oh, husband, you spent all your money on Lu Bu.
Now we're homeless.
Oh, why did nobody stop me?
Alright, I guess we'll do the Sun Jian one.
I don't even remember what we were at, at this point.
Alright.
I still haven't recovered financially.
No, I haven't.
No, this is Lu Bei.
Lu Bei, I'll do your shit later.
I need to do the Sun Jian one.
Oh, he's so cool.
He's so fucking cool.
Also, I realized I didn't even adjust my sound.
I...
I saved it.
Give me a sec.
Let me find it real quick.
I just realized that.
I was like, wait a minute.
That...
Why does it seem, like, really loud?
Okay.
Dynasty Warrior.
I always save the settings.
Oh, okay.
It's not that bad.
Alright, nice.
It's not loud.
It was actually quiet.
Okay.
It's usually here, I believe.
Alright, nice.
We were just okay.
Okay.
Now I have to look at the map.
Where do I go?
Oh, it's right here.
Is that Sun Jian?
Are you Sun Jian?
Oh, there you are.
Oh my god, you're right next to us.
That is so convenient.
Thank you.
Alright.
Oh my god.
We're going straight into without romancing any generals today?
Yes, guys.
Today is our lucky day because I already...
I already talked to everybody before the last...
Before the last playthrough ended.
Zhou Yu?
Are you coming to this battle this time?
You're...
The prince's very good...
Very, very, very, very good friend.
I need to get a fucking cough drop before I continue.
You must ensure the safety of both the present and future of the Sun clan.
There's no need to be dramatic.
My father and I...
I like how everyone's like, he's still alive?
I know.
I've never played a game where he's lived this long before.
Unless you're playing as Sun Jian and you defy his death.
My father and I are both capable of taking care of ourselves.
Oh, that is heavy foreshadowing right there.
Besides, you're the one making the decisions here, Zhou Yu.
You're worth more than...
Wow!
Sun Jian!
You're worth more than either of us.
He says...
In front of his fucking father?
Well, I suppose we are both important in our own...
Like, his father is right there.
Let us be careful not to put ourselves at risk.
Now, please allow me to outline our plan to assault the castle.
We'll have three main points of attack.
Lord Hong Dan from the front, Lord Chen Pu from the east, and Sun Tze from the west.
Lord Hong Dan will attack the base, drawing the enemy's attention.
He'll then start building a ramp to break through the castle.
He's still around?
Hong Dan?
Meanwhile, Chen Pu will advance from the east, capture the base there, and ring fire arrows on the castle.
This will silence the Confuser Mundo inside.
Once the fire is visible to them, Sun Tze's force will storm from the west, taking the castle.
An excellent plan, Zhou Yu.
I look forward to seeing you put it into action.
Thank you, sir.
Not joking, you may act at your discretion.
But you can take care of Zhou Yu for us as well.
I'm sure he'll find commanding easier with your help.
Oh, I can get Zhou Yu as my companion?
Oh my god, I bet he's very jealous right now.
Oh man.
You may know your roles to fulfill them as best as you can now.
To battle!
Alright, let's see.
Is there anything I need to do?
Alright, Yuan Shao, perform...
Perform...
Is there anyone that I want to, like, do well with?
What the fuck?
No.
If I have to, I'll pay for it.
I am not doing that.
I am absolutely not doing that.
Okay, gauntlets, okay.
They want me to use gauntlets.
Okay, battle arts, battle arts.
Alright, I just need to use battle arts.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Okay, let me grab...
Oh, I cannot change it.
Okay, now I can change, right?
I cannot change it.
Okay, now I can change.
Where the fuck is my gauntlets?
Okay, there we go.
Let's go.
Alright, get over here.
Wait, are you bad people?
You are.
I couldn't tell.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, I am not used to...
I am not used to using the fucking fists right now.
It's okay.
These guys don't have names, so they're gonna be really easy to kill.
That's right.
I'm gonna fist you!
I'm gonna fist all of you!
That's right!
Easy.
Sorry, I didn't hear what he said.
Alright, let's go.
Wait, did I actually do it correctly?
I can't tell.
I can't tell sometimes.
Okay, I did.
Okay, good.
Oh my god, we're just 60?
Oh, shit, nice.
Let's go.
I don't think I'm supposed to fight them.
I should walk back.
Oh, I...
Oh, oh, I...
Oh, I fucked up.
I don't think I'm supposed to fight them.
Okay, okay, he went back.
Okay, that's good.
That's good, that's good.
They reset themselves.
Okay, that's good, guys.
They reset themselves, guys.
I didn't fuck it up.
I didn't fuck it up for everybody.
Okay.
Nice.
Where are you?
Where did he go?
Okay.
Guys, we did it, guys.
I might have accidentally started the fight, but we did it.
Okay, now what do we do?
Zhou Yu, what's the plan?
Wait, again?
Oh shit, there's more?
How many more castles do I have to take?
Yeah, where is it?
Zhou Yu, where the fuck is the signal?
Zhou Yu, I did everything I told you!
Where the fuck is the signal?
Are we not?
Oh my god, Zhou Yu!
Wait, did I accidentally use my power-up?
Oh shit, okay.
That was not what I wanted to do, but that's alright.
At least I can still beat him up.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
I cannot counter with this one.
I don't know how to counter.
Okay.
Alright, dragons!
Do your thing!
Go do your thing, dragons!
I don't think you did anything, but that's okay.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, nice!
I've actually countered with my fists.
Oh my god, I fucking did it.
That's right.
I'm here to end your entire family line.
Oh my god, where did you come from?
Okay, that's fine.
I can also end your family line too.
That's fine.
It's not exclusive to everybody.
I'll give it out for free.
You don't need to thank me.
And then I can take your wife too.
She will be a widow anyway.
No, I keep accidentally using my power-up!
We did our best.
Maybe not good enough.
Okay, nice.
Get out of here.
Yay, I got a base now.
Okay.
Okay, now I got the fire arrows.
I thought he said like take one base.
When did it become like three?
Oh my god, who died?
Oh, it's her.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
We have...
Sun Jian has a lot of children.
So I'm okay with that.
Although they do keep dying.
So like...
That is a huge issue though.
The only issue is that his kids do keep dying.
So like I don't know what to do about that.
But don't worry.
He has a lot of concubines.
I believe in him.
Jesus Christ, how many generals do you have?
I'm still killing them?
How am I still killing generals?
Jesus!
Oh yeah, Zhou Yu has done well.
He only...
Oh my god, I fucking kicked him off of high ground and I can't jump.
That's the worst part.
Okay.
That's fine.
We got him though.
Get out of here.
Get...
Oh okay, she's dead.
Whoops.
Okay.
Your daughter might not be alive anymore.
But like it's not my fault.
I swear to god.
She just wasn't...
I think maybe stop sending child soldiers?
Like...
I think if you stop sending child soldiers into the battle field, then maybe like...
You know.
Maybe they won't have died?
I don't know.
Okay, nice.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, it's a unique attack.
Oh, it's the extreme Musou attack.
Okay, we don't need to do that.
Okay, we gotta help the people down there.
I'm just saying.
If they stop sending children generals to the battle field, maybe things won't be that bad.
I don't know.
Okay, let's just help him.
Oh my god, he didn't even need help anyway.
Rest in peace, daughter.
Skill issue, obviously.
Exactly, that's what I'm saying!
Alright, Dragoon, are you okay if there's a general in front of you guys?
Well...
The Dragoons are like, wait a minute.
Why are you putting us in the middle of a fight?
And you guys all get like fucking shot at.
Sorry.
Sorry about that.
It was an accident, Dragoons.
I swear.
Ew.
You got the job done though.
I appreciate it, guys.
Nice.
Oh my god, wait.
He also had hands.
Are they better hands?
Oh no, they are not as good.
Wait, what do I...
Oh wait, no.
They're actually better.
Wait, okay.
But am I done with this?
No, I am not done.
I am...
What?
Okay.
I still need...
Okay, I need to do battle arts.
Okay.
That's fine.
Wait, who?
Oh my god, you also need help?
Please!
There's so many Generals!
Can't help you all!
Oh my god.
It said...
Okay, destroy this.
I don't know what it is.
Destroy it.
Okay, we gotta make sure Sun Jian doesn't fucking die though.
Oh, he's so healthy.
Oh, he's fine.
Oh no, I have to reconstruct it?!
Okay, this is a little awkward.
Okay, Chen Po, you might have to die too.
War is about sacrifices.
As long as, like, you know...
Sun Tze and...
Oh my god.
I'm sorry!
We're taking so long!
Okay, goodbye Chen Po.
Alright, so...
Remember when the strategy was supposed to be like...
Jesus Christ!
Remember when Zhou Yu's strategy was like...
We all take, like, a specific area and then we do a pincer attack?
We do a three-way pincer attack?
Well, it's just gonna be a two-way pincer attack now.
I hope that doesn't change the strategy too much.
I hope...
Yeah, it's gonna be a two...
Remember when I said it's a two-way pincer attack?
It's actually gonna be a one-way attack.
I hope...
I hope it doesn't change the strategy too much, guys.
That one-way pincer attack that we all wanted in the beginning?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
We all know pincer attacks are supposed to be one-way, right?
That's the whole point!
It's five.
It's gonna be it's so five.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
There we go.
We did it!
Okay, just one more left.
Just one guy.
Right here.
Oh, it's just the archer.
Alright, get outta here!
Get that archer outta here!
And then we should have a battering ram, right?
Okay.
Guys, that's alright, guys.
As long as they...
Everybody...
Who is fighting in the middle?
Oh my...
Okay, we gotta...
We gotta make sure...
How did he get there?
Okay, let's go help.
Okay, that's not good.
That's not good.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I'm coming over.
I'm almost there.
Oh my god.
Wait, he's taking them all there.
Oh, he wants to duel?
Who is he?
Oh, you wanna duel?
Give me a sec.
Oh, just...
Oh, you're like...
Finally, another fist stamp.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
Let me grab this real quick.
Let me change this weapon real quick, guys.
He's like, finally!
Another fist stamp!
That's what I wanted to fight against!
Sorry, buddy.
No!
Fist stamp!
Alright, nice.
Alright, now...
Now, I'm going back to the fist.
Okay, now I'm going back to my...
To what I was actually trying to do.
Yeah.
Okay.
Can we break his stuff?
And then we get him out of here, too.
Alright.
Bye.
Oh, shit!
Goodbye.
That's all it takes.
Wait, there's like one more guy right here guarding the door.
He's like, surely there's nobody behind us, right?
Don't worry, guys.
I've got the front gate.
Alright, okay.
You guys won't fuck it up this time, right, dragons?
You guys got it.
Nice.
Boom!
That's right.
Okay, how's my objective now?
88?
Am I not...
Oh, yeah, I'm not using the battle armor.
I am absolutely not doing it correctly.
Oh, my God!
You guys finally got in!
Finally!
Everybody's dead by the way.
Everybody's dead.
But they did it, guys!
They fucking did it!
I'm proud of you guys.
You guys did it.
Wait, is that...
That's the...
Oh, that's the big guy.
Okay, I couldn't tell.
There's so many people here.
Wait, I have Extreme Musou!
But you know what that means.
It's Jo-Yu time.
That's fucking right.
And I can be angry!
Boom!
Oh, my God!
Okay, alright.
That was...
That was really fast.
Okay.
This is a little not fair right now.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
Oh, you thought...
You thought you could do an unstoppable move?
There's nothing...
There's no such thing as unstoppable moves.
Oh, and then I can do it again!
The double whammy!
Let's go!
Get over here!
I can be double angry!
That's right!
Nice.
It was just that easy.
I can be angry twice.
I have a lot of hate in me.
I...
There we go.
Hate is unlimited!
Yippee!
Mood.
Whoa!
Sun Tze doesn't mean that!
Sun Tze!
He doesn't mean that!
Sorry, guys.
We're just really good friends, too.
Papa Smurf!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
What's it like?
You heard that us Asians are so short because not doki systematically hunted down.
All it takes are people in ancient China!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Kogashi!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Joyu is my ROTK oshi.
I miss this.
I know!
Me, too!
I feel like the staff just doesn't...
I don't know.
I think the sword is more Joyu style.
I know they wanted more, like, unique.
Like, unique weapons for everybody.
But I honestly think the...
I honestly think Joyu's sword is just so iconic to him.
Okay, uh...
I want more meat buns.
We need more meat buns.
Alright.
Mission success.
We just need to do one more Sun Tien mission, I believe?
Yeah, the sword is just cooler.
Thank you, Joyu.
Everything worked out because of you.
I don't know what I'd do without you around.
Woah!
I could say the same for you.
Are we just watching this?
Where am I?
Oh, I am watching this.
I am watching.
We're...
The whole family is watching?!
Holy shit!
The whole family is in the corner?!
Damn.
Derrick's... aww!
Oh my god, his dad approves!
Woah.
Yeah.
I don't...
You're not...
You're definitely not gonna willingly retire.
Don't worry, sir.
You're gonna be great to hear that you don't retire.
That night...
Oh, wait.
I don't like it when it goes nighttime.
Okay, that's good.
Okay, that's fine.
Nothing bad is happening at night.
Oh my god!
An Asian father actually giving him approval?
To his son?
Oh my god, this is rare.
This truly is a fantasy game.
Realistic!
Oh.
Um.
Woah.
Glad to hear that.
Guy who's gonna die soon.
Wow!
Sun Jian!
We're so in sync!
Wow!
Sun Jian!
We're so in sync!
Wow!
Excellent!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
We need Doki to react to Kung Fu and martial arts scenes in movies.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
He's self-aware.
Oh.
Does he have self-doubt?
About his lord?
Are you having doubt to our lord?
I'm gonna report you.
Yeah, what made you think so?
Huh?
Are you gonna defy our lord?
Sun Jian?
After everything he's done?
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Nice save.
You're right.
He is.
Alright, I won't report you.
I once aimed to be the same as him.
Or even surpass him.
But now I couldn't possibly.
It's okay guys, he saved it.
Anyway, that is enough ruminating for me.
It is time to focus.
Surviving these upcoming battles will require every ounce of our strength.
You will have a major part to play as well.
What do I have?
Oh, cool!
Another major part that I'll play where you're gonna re- And then you're just gonna rewrite me out of history.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah, I love doing that.
Hey there, guys.
Hey there, roommates.
Yeah, you're supposed to be talking about him.
What's with Yuan Shu?
Even Yuan Shao is no match for him.
Don't you agree?
I suppose you're right.
If Lord Sun Jian does defeat Liu Biao and take over Jing Province...
...it is feasible that we could gain control of the entire land.
Now, that would be something!
I'm only a background character.
Okay.
I'm pretty much... I'm just like an OC that's just watching everything unfold in history.
I'm like my self-insert.
I'm basically a self-insert right now.
Wait, what was that entire cutscene for?
I don't understand.
Hello, Zhou Yu.
Oh, shit.
Hey, it is me.
You seem troubled.
Hello, or hello.
I'm listening.
Oh, wait, I'm supposed to be left-side Doki.
Fuck, I keep forgetting.
All right, right-side Doki.
Goodbye.
Okay, that's not right.
Okay, I need to remember which one's left-side Doki, guys.
All right, there we go.
Okay, he should be dead.
This is called like survival of the fittest and like natural selection.
Natural selection is literally trying to kill this guy.
Stop saving him.
You care about him deeply.
Okay, I'm just gonna be a wingman, I guess.
Yeah, we won.
Oh, but you can, right, Zhou Yu?
An interesting story.
Okay, I'm just like, uh-huh.
Yeah, that's interesting.
I wonder what you'll do next.
That's a cool story, bro.
Whoa!
Have you asked Sun Tzu's permission yet, though?
Have you?
Our fates are intertwined.
You heard that, guys?
Damn, they all want me.
My self-insert that I wrote myself in.
Okay, let's talk to this old man.
You must be that warrior I've heard about.
I can see in your face.
You're ready.
Take this with you.
Okay, nice.
Oh, I have the sword.
Okay, I gotta steal that.
All right, and then we'll do the- wait, what?
Oh, it's just weapons.
Okay, I thought that.
God, I'm still so poor.
Wait, I can sell some stuff.
Wait, I forgot.
I forgot my- the most important part.
Just selling stuff.
Oh, I almost sold- I almost wanted to sell this.
I did not see.
How strong- they're not like- okay, sword.
Okay, I was gonna say.
Oh, I didn't- you have to sort them yourself.
Oh, I see.
Okay, we're still selling that for sure.
And sell this.
Okay, sell that.
Almost there, guys.
We almost have enough.
Okay.
Oh my god, we need a thousand more.
No, I'm still broke.
No.
No, wait, there's an offering.
I gotta go there.
Where am I?
Wait, where am I?
Oh, there's an offering there.
They've heard the tales.
Oh, I got mahogany.
Let's go.
Oh my god, they just gave me a fucking horse.
Nice.
What is this?
Is this where- Is this green or blue?
I can never tell anymore.
I can't tell.
Where is this?
Is this green or blue?
Someone tell me.
It's over here.
Oh, that's green, right?
Yeah, that's- oh, no, it's red.
It was neither.
Wait, am I- oh shit.
Okay, am I like high enough level?
Oh, yeah, I am.
All right.
Nice, it's red.
It was neither green or blue.
It was red.
All right.
All here?
Yes.
Leading the attack.
Now.
The enemy is currently- Uh, wait, maybe I can stop this from happening.
Breaking through their easy defense to defend- to attack the stronghold will take time.
Okay, let me look at this.
Okay, if I go from here...
to here and then I rush through everybody and then I'm gonna prevent history.
All right.
And I would like to ask you, Lord, uh...
Sun Jian to lead a separate force and push the entire front line forward.
By coordinating movements and breaking through the defense, we will make Xian Yan ours.
Make no mistake.
This will not be easy.
Lu Biao is formidable and this is his domain.
But we have an advantage here.
We will overwhelm the enemy and defeat them in one decisive blow.
I'll accompany Lord Sun Jian, not Zhou Qi.
I want you to support the main force.
Zhou Yu and the princess will also be there to assist Lord Sun Jian.
I trust you to do what you think is best.
All right, guys, don't worry.
I will change the fate.
I will change history!
Don't worry!
I got this!
All right, let me get my best weapon out there.
Don't worry, guys.
I shall change history!
Okay, I just need to go all the way down here.
And then, okay, this is what I'm gonna be doing, guys.
I gotta go all the way down here, take this cassa, and then go all the way around and then I'll reach him.
If you could change our fate, would ya?
All right, here we go.
I don't care how many gen- oh, shit.
Okay, this is not looking too good already.
I don't care how- oh, fuck.
This is not looking good already.
I- What the fuck?!
Okay, I don't care how many people will die, but we shall save- we shall change history!
Okay, I just have to keep going.
It'll be fine.
It's just that easy, guys.
Don't worry.
I just gotta keep going for it.
There we go.
Don't worry, we're almost there!
I'm gonna change history!
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
I need to get him out of the way real fast, though.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
I finished it.
There we go.
Don't worry!
Trust me!
I shall change the fate!
Open the doors!
Wait, what the fuck?
Where did all these guys come from?
I don't think they noticed me, though.
It's fine.
Don't worry!
I can do this!
Don't worry, Sujin!
I'm coming over!
Okay, don't worry, we're almost there!
We're almost there!
Sujin!
Just give me a sec, Sujin!
It's okay, Sujin.
I'll be right back.
Give me a sec.
This is taking a little while.
This is taking a little while, though.
Please!
He takes so long to kill!
Don't kill their head!
Don't worry!
I still need to kill this guy!
Okay.
Oh my god.
This is gonna take fucking forever.
Why are you so strong?
I'm fucking- I'm bringing another- Okay, I must have a stronger- I must have a stronger weapon.
Oh, it's just by one, though.
Goddamn it.
I knew I should not- if I didn't spend all that money.
If I didn't spend all that money.
Oh my god!
Why did I spend all the money on Lu Bu?!
Why?!
Why did I spend all that money?!
If only I had more money for a stronger weapon!
Oh my god!
Okay, that's fine.
Don't worry!
We can- we can still do this!
Open the gate!
I'm here to change the history of time!
We're almost there!
Surely, I can like open it from the back side, right?
Wait, can I just open it now?
Okay, good.
All right, that's good.
I don't even have to kill him.
Okay, that is great.
I don't even have to kill this guy.
Come on, open the door!
No!
Don't, Sun Jian!
Stop!
No!
Somebody stop him!
Somebody!
No!
Somebody stop him!
We're so close!
No!
Cut him in half!
Oh my god!
No!
Beware what?
What?
What the fuck?
Where am I?
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
No!
He won't let me change history!
I'm so fucked up!
Why?
What the fuck?
I can't believe it!
I'm not allowed to change history!
They're like...
It was not planned!
That's not fair!
I worked so hard to get here!
What do you mean I'm not allowed to change history?
I can't believe it!
How am I supposed to kill him?
The top police is here!
Oh my god!
I'm actually not allowed to change history!
That's not fair!
I'm so messed up!
How do I kill him?
Yes!
I want to save him!
Oh my god!
I can't save him!
I'm so low!
Holy shit!
What the fuck?
Guys...
Guys, I don't think I can save him.
I don't think...
Guys...
Guys, the top police got me!
I don't think I'm meant to...
I don't think I'm meant to save him!
I just gotta get good!
Believe in yourself.
This is the hardest date.
You can alter fate?
Wait!
Are you serious?
Wait, how many fates have I forgot to alter?
I'm not an actual thing.
Wait, have I missed out on other alterations?
Oh, this is the first one.
Okay.
Okay, guys, I don't think I can save him.
Guys, the time police kicked my ass, guys.
Guys, the time police...
Guys, the time police kicked my ass.
I don't think I can... Goodbye.
Goodbye.
It's too late.
Never give up.
Goodbye, soon-chan.
I tried.
Never mess with history, guys.
Don't mess with history, guys.
I've learned my lessons.
Don't leave.
You're just gonna let him...
Guys, we tried, okay?
At least I can say I tried.
Okay, guys, I tried to alter fate.
Okay, that's better than anything.
Is it trying better than not doing nothing, guys?
Guys, at least I tried.
It's better than doing nothing, guys.
It's better than doing nothing, though.
Don't...
Don't... Exactly.
I did my best.
It's okay.
It was meant to die anyway.
It was a canon event.
It's worse because you wasted time.
But I did it, though.
I did it.
I tried my best.
This is all that matters.
There we go.
I did it.
Yeah, like, you know, he already lived for a very long time, though.
He already, like, lived for as long as he could.
So he should be happy about that.
He, like...
He, like, lived for so long.
It's fine.
That's fine.
We knew he was gonna die anyway.
We were all set up for it, guys.
It's not like we didn't know.
No.
No, it's okay.
No, it's fine.
I don't...
It's okay.
No, it's fine.
I don't need to save him.
I already know what's gonna happen to me.
What the fuck am I trying to kill?
Alright, nice.
Come on!
If Lu Bu was here, he would've... No, it's fine.
It's okay.
Go in there, dragoons!
It's fine.
Alright, goodbye, Sun Jian.
It was great knowing you.
I'm sorry the time police stopped me.
Look.
They sent their best, okay?
They sent really strong people.
What was I supposed to do, guys?
What could I have done, guys?
What could I have done differently?
I've done everything I could.
Try harder.
The hell?
How do you do this one?
Regis, defeat with X attacks from either...
How do I do this one?
Am I doing this correctly?
I can't tell.
Okay, nice.
It's fine.
Oh my god, it's not fine!
There's too many people in front of me.
Like, where...
I can't see anything!
What's going on?!
Okay, it's fine.
It's not fine, but it's fine.
It's not fine.
I do not feel okay right now.
There's way too many things going on.
Oh my god!
I can't move!
I'm kidding.
I can't move.
I actually can't move right now.
There's so many of them.
Oh my god!
What's going on?!
I...
What the fuck is going on?!
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's not fine.
Now this is how I imagine times 2 Warriors.
Guys, we knew this was gonna happen.
We were prepared, like, since part 1, guys.
Oh!
Oh shit!
What a way to go, guys.
Imagine just getting a giant rock thrown at you.
That's it.
Yeah, that's how he dies, apparently.
No, not the morale!
Please, I'm going through so much right now.
I can't fucking move!
I can't move.
We'll retreat?
I just...
What the fuck?
I went through so much.
Would you be more gonna retreat?
I went through so much and he's gonna call for a retreat?!
That's so fucked up.
This is... I don't even know what's going on.
And he's gonna call for a retreat.
This is fucked up.
What do you mean, Dragoon?
What do you mean?!
We've been through so much!
What the fuck do you mean we gotta fall back?!
What the fuck do you mean fall back?!
We had to go through so much!
Fall back.
There we go.
I'm gonna kill him.
I don't care.
I'm gonna kill him if it's the last thing I do.
It's harder than Lu Bu?!
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy that this is considered harder than Lu Bu.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Get me out of here!
Please.
Let me just kill him.
At least grant me that pleasure.
At least grant me this pleasure of killing this guy.
I don't know who he is.
I just wanna kill him.
Please.
I just...
That is literally the one thing I want in life.
Just grant me that.
There we go.
Okay, now I'll go back.
That's all I want.
Just grant me that pleasure.
I don't care.
Okay.
I went through so much, guys.
I went through so much.
Okay, now I can start fisting again.
I need to figure out how to...
Oh shit.
Okay.
I'm trying to figure out how to do the other thing for this.
Get that battle in.
Okay.
I think it's this, right?
Did I do it?
I don't know.
Oh my god!
Please, PC!
Live!
Live, PC!
Don't live!
I need you to live, PC!
I don't want to watch the Jedi again!
Oh, look at that.
Wow, he's not here to fucking stop me this time.
The time police realized that I failed.
Okay.
That's right.
Get out of here.
Okay.
Nice.
Counter.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here!
Alright.
Is there any bread?
Any bread?
Any fucking bread for me?
Oh, nope.
Alright.
Fuck me, I guess.
Um, yeah.
We sort of, like, threw a rock on him.
And he sort of died.
I like how he just steered up.
I guess, like, you can't really dodge a rock, you know?
I'm a wiser.
I could have avoided this.
I fucking hate these guys to lose.
I- I like this so hard!
HUNG GUY, PLEASE GET OVER HERE AND HELP!
HUNG GUY!
I CAN'T APPROACH!
Oh my go- Okay, that's okay.
The family helped.
It's okay.
The family helped out.
I really appreciate it.
Okay, we finally finished that stance.
Jesus Christ, I hated that stance so much.
Okay, sword time.
Sword time.
Okay, get out of here.
Any fellow breads in chat?
Any?
Any breads in chat?
I need some bread.
What do you mean?
We're, like, next to each other.
Okay.
What do you mean?
Eat your bread!
Eat your bread, everybody!
Good!
Okay, there we go.
They did it.
Oh, there he is!
Wait, I should kill this guy.
I forgot about him.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
This is a little worrying because, um, I have no HP.
This is very worrying, guys.
I have no HP right now for this fight.
How do they have all the bread?
I should be able to eat some of their bread, too, afterwards.
If I see my allies, I should get healed.
Like, how come they can get healed but I can't?
Oh my god, that's fine.
I just need to do one hit.
I just need to do one more hit.
There we go.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god he held bread on him.
Alright.
Can you escape now?
Can you guys escape now?
Alright, don't worry.
I'll kill him for you.
Oh shit, Julia!
Julia!
I forgot to give you bread!
I forgot!
The one guy that was crying for bread and I never gave him.
I never gave him the bread.
Whoops, my bad.
My bad.
That was my bad.
I'm sorry.
I forgot you were the one that asked for it.
Okay, let's kill him real fast.
Guys, see?
It doesn't matter if I save Sun Jian because I wasn't going to do his route anyway.
Okay, we'll let these guys deal with the other two.
Okay, we need to help Sun Jian escape here.
Wait, is he actually in danger?
There's no way.
That's silly.
OH FUCK!
He ate your bread!
See?
He's not in danger now.
Guys, look.
See?
He's not in danger now, guys.
It's fine.
It's fine, guys.
He's okay now.
That's all that matters.
Oh shit, the veterans are here.
Okay, arrows.
This is it.
This is your time to shine.
Is he doing it?
Oh my god, he's doing it!
He's doing it!
Get him out of here!
Get out!
Oh my god, he's so much taller!
Why is he so tall?
He's so fucking tall!
It's not fair!
Bro, he's not even fighting back!
He's just fucking sending people else to die!
Just like a true general.
Oh, nice.
I can take his staff too.
Nice, he's going for mine now.
Alright.
I'll help out the others.
Kill him!
Your kings must die!
You're right.
Alright.
We gotta kill him too.
I need to know what- What is my objective?
Okay, not this one.
What's the sword one?
Tactics, launch a successful charge, Sword training, Sword training, Defeat 200 foes with battle arts.
Oh my god, it's just literally all battle arts.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm here for you guys!
I'm here for the short king!
If we eliminate all the tall people, then we can win.
We just gotta eliminate all the tall people.
Okay.
Let's go.
Let's get rid of this guy.
Then the short- Guys, then the short king will become- The short king will become the tall people.
If we just eliminate all the taller people.
Okay, I'm just gonna kill these guys.
With this.
I'm ready to get mad.
Eat the tall.
Then we will become tall.
Oh my god.
We'll become the thing that we sell to destroy.
That's fucking right.
I won't have it any other way.
Then you'll have to eliminate the short kings.
Right after.
Get out.
I need your bread.
God, you're so not important.
Oh no, no.
It's fine.
He'll come back.
Give me a sec.
I'll come back soon.
Oh my god, please.
I'm dealing with this right now.
You'll be fine.
You'll be so fine.
I just need to kill him real quick.
I swear to god I'll come back.
Okay, nice.
Okay, he's almost dead.
I swear to god I'll come back for you.
There we go.
Nice.
I did it.
Okay, I'll come back for you guys.
I swear to god.
I promise.
I'm coming over.
I'm coming over, guys.
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
Just eat your bread.
Eat your bread, everybody.
Eat your bread.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay, okay.
She's okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, sister, you gotta get out of here.
You actually gotta get out of here.
You actually...
Oh, no.
Oh, this is awkward.
This is a little awkward.
This is awkward.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
He's okay, guys.
Guys, he's okay, guys.
He's...
He's okay, everybody.
No close shaves at all.
He's all fucked up.
Oh, shit.
I'm not okay, though.
Bro,
where are you?
Okay, okay.
I made him eat bread.
I told you it would be fine.
Let's get serious.
He's so strong.
Why is he so strong?
Okay.
Everything was fine.
Come on, guys, please.
Please, guys.
Please.
I watched him die in front of me.
Oh, my God.
Jesus Christ.
I'm trying my best right now.
There's so many people.
Jesus.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I'm 1 HP.
Please.
I'm blocking everything I can.
I'm blocking everything I can right now.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Please give me your bread.
Oh, thank God.
I live a little bit longer.
Jesus Christ.
They're so strong.
Blasted.
I'm dead.
Okay.
Live.
Just live.
I'm trying my best to kill them.
I'm literally a one-man army.
Oh, my God.
Why are you running?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Actually, fuck you, though.
Actually, fuck you for running away.
I'm like trying to...
I'm trying to fucking do my best.
Okay.
I'm not letting you do this.
Yeah, you're not getting away with that.
I am trying to end this.
Don't worry.
Wait, did somebody die?
Oh, he made it.
Oh, my God.
He made it.
I can't even take him.
I can't even take his soul.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
We don't need it.
We don't need his fucking soul.
Usagi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I respect you, your talent, and your life choices, but I'm loyal to Lu Bu.
Thank you for the super chat, Usagi.
Thank you.
All right, let's see.
What did I completed?
Okay, I completed that.
Nice.
Okay, I just need to do 200 and 300 more.
Oh, nice.
I completed a lot.
Whoa.
Okay.
I don't know how to do this one.
The dramatic success one is really difficult.
Okay, we're never completing that.
We're never completing that.
Uh, all right.
Nice.
Wait.
Oh.
I want to step on them.
Okay, we definitely need this.
Like, fuck the arrows.
Actually, fuck the arrows.
They're the bane of my existence right now.
Um, Alcarion, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I saved Sun Jian in my first playthrough.
It was way harder than beating Lu Bu.
And since I wasn't doing Lu's story first, it was a waste of time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
See, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter that he died, guys.
Look, the time police was just way too strong.
I can't do it.
This is my failure.
An irreparable one at that.
Is that meant to shoot?
Oh yeah, I know.
I fucking killed a lot of them.
They literally killed one.
Okay, they killed a lot of our generals too.
But they're okay.
They're just wounded.
But I killed a lot of their generals.
I don't know.
That's right.
Sun Jian who has lived a very good long life as well.
Nothing's gonna happen to him too.
Alright.
Cool.
Sorry to say that after this, I'm not gonna do anything with you guys after.
Aw, Sun Jian.
That's so rough, buddy.
But I'm still picking green.
That's rough, man.
Tell me what?
Zhou Yu!
You're gonna leave your...
Why?
Just because he's depressed, you don't just leave him?
Oh my god.
That's not true love, guys.
He's leaving him when he needs him the most.
Depressed?
Depression?
Not a true homie.
Yeah, but...
Shouldn't we help directly?
Yeah, shouldn't we help directly, Zhou Yu?
That doesn't matter!
He needs the comfort of his really, really, really good friend and roommate.
He needs comfort!
Especially at...
Alright.
Peace has...
Yo, I received a letter!
Oh my god, another super chat?
Oh shit, okay, no.
Let's meet up for...
You are not...
You are not relevant enough to score this character.
Not Doki, are you well?
Please forgive me for treating you so coldly.
If you ever find yourself in need of help, you need but ask.
If it's for you, I would be willing to do everything in my power to be of assistance.
As for me, I finally got a hold of myself.
I decided to focus my efforts solely on what I can do right now to prepare for the coming restoration of the House of Sun.
Alright.
Remember that place we went?
Sorry Hongdae, I went to a lot of places with a lot of different generals.
You gotta be more specific.
I wanna go again, so join me for a spell.
Why am I inviting you, you ask?
It's simple.
You're not the type to let people down.
That much is very clear to me.
Sorry to take advantage of your sense of responsibility.
Oh my god, he's guilt tripping me because he's so pathetic.
Oh my god.
He...
Alright.
Those are inside thoughts.
Okay, where is he?
Where is he?
Where is this guy?
Alright.
I don't remember.
Guys, he said, do you remember that time where we ate that meal together?
I don't.
I do not remember, man.
Why would I remember?
Oh my god.
Where is he?
It just says shampoo.
It doesn't even...
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
There it is.
I found the restaurant.
Wait, I should be able to afford the strong weapons now.
Okay, I can.
Which one?
This is the...
Orchids is the strongest, right?
Guys, is it the orchids or the sword that's the strongest weapon?
Which one was it?
I can only buy one.
Which one was it, guys?
I don't remember.
Chat.
Orchids?
Okay.
Wait, one guy said it.
I need to know the strongest...
Okay, okay.
I'll buy the orchids then.
Nice.
Alright.
I'm back.
Wow!
First...
The first...
Really, the first thing you're gonna say.
He's a bottom.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's so sad.
That's so sad, bro.
Oh, baby.
That's so sad.
Why are you so pathetic?
Guys, why is he so pathetic, guys?
And he starts the sentence with I want your meat.
Huh?
Okay, I shouldn't be that mean.
What do you mean?
You are not making this more attractive, sir.
Ah,
yes.
Me defeating Lu Bu.
So not standing out.
What?
This is like such a backhanded compliment.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The tall people are in the way of your BL.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I understand how you feel.
So now you can eat and drink to your heart's content.
If I treat you to that, it'll be hard to turn me down, right?
Is that how it goes?
I'll really be counting on you once you're ready.
Since I believe you understand what's required.
You are girl failure, he is guy failure.
You two are perfect for each other.
Oh no, our bond is stronger now.
Attack this as well to become the strongest boss.
Someday soon, you'll be the pillar of Wu.
Alright.
Let's leave.
Alright, let's see.
Life swipe!
Thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hong Dang, are you and Lu Bu still together?
He's like...
He's just like, this is it.
This is my time to shine.
Jeez.
Alright, do I get any...
Do I have any extra?
No, I still haven't.
Okay, uh, interactions.
Um...
Okay, Chen Pu.
Okay, let's see like...
Give me a sec.
Let me see what I have to complete.
I don't know if I want to pay for this one.
He's not like that important in my scale.
Or strong attack using a...
Oh my god, fucking hell.
Finish with enhanced final blow using...
Oh my god.
Okay, yeah, we're paying for it.
We're paying for it.
Yeah.
Oh, I broke.
Never mind.
I'll pay for it later.
I'll pay for it later, guys.
Okay, uh...
We need to find Chen Pu.
He wants to start something with me.
It's somewhere here.
Uh...
Where the fuck?
Where is it?
Oh, there he is.
Never mind.
I found him.
Hello.
You...
You asked for me!
I literally rode a boat just to talk...
I rode a boat for one month just to talk to you.
That was a long ship ride.
The loss of Lord Sun Jian has thrown the house as soon into turmoil.
To escape this mire, we need as many talented people as we can get.
I can see your potential, so I offer you this.
Hone your skills.
I am sure that one day, you will be indispensable to this clan.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
More training.
Alright, now we gotta do the last Lu Bei mission.
Should be here.
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back, guys.
This has been the most fights we've ever gotten.
I'm not gonna lie.
Actually, it's been the most actual gameplay we've gotten today.
I've already romanced all the generals.
And I'm back!
I'm back, everybody.
Where is this?
Alright, there we go.
Battle of Bei Hai.
Oh, I'm like two levels above.
It should be fine.
Marsha, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
So you can't refuse if we buy you dinner first.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alan, Duck, Mike, Solid.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, I'm here.
Lu Bei.
We're now in Bei Hai.
Our co-assistant governor, Lord Kong Rong.
According to Lord Tai Shi Si, his castle is being besieged by the remnants of the Yellow Turban.
Okay, there he is.
We cannot let Kong Rong Lord Kong Rong Lord Kong Rong fall to their blades in the meantime.
Our priority is keeping him safe.
There are reports of siege weapons among the enemy formation.
I would recommend keeping an eye on the castle gates.
And we gotta make sure Lu Bei survives.
Of course, same with Tai Shi Si who will be guiding us on the field.
But he's blue.
He's a blue guy.
Why are we letting him in here?
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just got my gamer subs already.
Oh yeah, a lot of people don't keep What?
He's part of blue team.
How dare we let a blue man in here fighting with the greens.
Let's go.
It's cool, sparkly cup and t-shirt.
Ah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad that all the gamer subs stuff is starting to come... arrive.
I'm so happy about that.
I actually got the t-shirt like a while ago.
I think like two months ago.
But like obviously I'm getting them like...
I wanted to wear it, but then like two months ago but then I was just like, wait, no one else has it.
Like, if I wear it in public If I wear it in public people will be like, wait a minute no one else has the shirt yet.
So I thank god I stopped myself before it happened.
There's much to keep in mind for this battle.
Be sure to stay vigilant.
What should I do?
With enough courage, we can stagger the enemy and break through their lines.
Once we reach the castle, our position will be assured, and we need only finish off the remaining enemies.
As always, it's a rough sort of plan, but I like it.
I'm grateful you answered its call.
I too will give you my all in the next battle.
Good luck.
Nice.
I have Guan Yun.
I do hope they make the next dynasty.
I do enjoy this one, but I hope they make their next dynasty warriors I can play as the actual generals, because that's the more fun part.
I know they want to do my self-insert OC here, but like it's just not the same, you know?
Playing as your favorite generals in the Three Kingdoms, just not the same.
Alright, nice.
That was easy.
That's right, beg.
That's fucked up.
I'm helping him, but he's just gonna leave me anyway.
Get outta here.
Get outta here!
Oh shit, I need to look at what I need to do.
Alright, perform Rage Mode.
Successful charge or ambush.
Win five duels while being injured.
Defeat 200.
Okay, I need to do the sword.
I keep forgetting the sword.
Foes of Ida.
The gauntlet.
Okay, sword time.
Okay, where's my sword?
Oh, I can't change it.
I was doing something really cool.
Okay, sword time.
Oh, I should've bought the sword just cause like I have to do the sword shit.
I should've bought the sword just for the sword mission.
Get over here.
I need to do this mission.
Get outta here!
Nice.
Oh my god, that was fast.
Alright, nice.
Yeah, should we go out and die?
So boring!
Man!
We should be out there dying!
Aw man!
That's crazy.
I would wanna be on lookout duty.
What the fuck?
I can't believe he said that.
That's crazy.
Like, I can't believe I had to go out there and like not potentially die?
I should be out there risking my life to be cannon fodder.
Okay.
How?
Where did he die?
Brave Karl Where?
Oh!
What the fuck?
You were all the way Don't wonder you fucking died!
Oh man!
Oh shit!
Oh!
Oh dude, the guards are- Oh I was- I forgot I'm supposed to be helping!
I'm the reinforcements!
I forgot- Sorry!
I forgot I was the reinforcements coming in.
I was like, what are you doing over there?
Oh wait, I'm supposed to be coming in to help you!
Sorry.
Don't worry, I'm coming over.
Don't worry, I'm here to help.
Okay mister, I'm pretty sure you killed a lot.
Wait, I'm right here guardian!
What do you mean?
I'm right here!
Excuse me?
I've been doing this my entire time!
Since part one!
How do I get third wheel like here?
That's so fucked up.
I'm literally right here.
I'm mad now I'm sending arrows out.
I'm so mad.
I'm gonna send out arrows.
Cause I'm mad now.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe guardian would say that in front of me.
After everything we've been through.
Look at this.
Look at this compact guardian.
Are you not entertained?
Is this not sexy enough?
I literally killed five generals for you buddy!
And I parried!
Look at me Guardian!
I parried!
Guardian!
I parried again!
Is that not hot?
Nothing sexier than the blood of my own enemy.
That's what I'm saying!
Exactly!
Really?
Okay nice.
We got another one.
Alright.
Let's help them out.
I got you general!
I nearly just killed him but okay.
Wait there's like Wait how do I get up there?
Give me a sec.
I gotta figure out how to get up there.
Okay I'm I did my job.
Okay nice.
Alright did I finish the objective for this one yet?
How much do I need?
Oh I'm almost there.
Alright we got this guy.
Give me a sec.
Oh fuck there's another one?
I'm trying!
Okay nice.
Oh nice!
Why you do your thing?
Yeah!
He did nothing but yeah!
Okay we just gotta kill this guy.
It's fine.
I'm not using my extreme musou guys.
It's not the time right now.
It's not the time!
Okay now I finished finally.
I can use my beefed up orchids.
There we go.
Now this should be easier to kill him.
C'mon get outta here.
My weapon is level 138 man.
Yeah!
Ooh.
Oh shit!
Okay I forgot about the downstairs people.
What the fuck?
What are you doing?
Hahaha!
Guys!
Get out!
Get outta here guys!
Get outta here!
What is that ladder gonna do?
What?
What the fuck was that ladder gonna do?
Oh no!
He's walking!
Oh shit!
Okay we gotta help Lupe!
Oh I forgot about- Oh fuck!
Okay don't worry I'm coming over Lupe!
Oh fuck!
Okay sorry.
Sorry I got too distracted by the ladder people.
I got distracted by the ladder people.
I'm sorry.
The ladder people took away a lot of my attention.
Wait where is Lupe?
Wait where is he?
Hahaha!
Oh shit!
He's back there!
Sorry!
Oh yeah yeah!
You're getting really fucked up.
Lupe don't worry!
Eat your bread!
Don't worry Lupe!
It's okay he ate his bread guys!
He ate his bread guys!
It's okay!
Don't worry!
I got- I came back in time!
Don't worry guys!
I- I did it!
Jesus Christ there's so many people here.
Like where is the- Oh there he is!
There's so many people here I couldn't see where the general was.
That's fucking right!
Get out!
I'm two levels higher!
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's do extreme Musou time.
Let's go.
It's a little bit extreme.
Oh fuck!
Okay nice.
Okay that might have been a little extreme though not gonna lie.
But it was worth it.
Get out!
Nice.
Wait where?
He's gonna secretly murder him.
I can see it.
I don't remember his part in history but like that's so sus.
That's so sus.
That's so suspicious.
I don't trust nobody here.
That's so suspicious!
Why does he really wanna go see him?
Okay nice.
That should be everybody right?
My god how is there still more?
Oh my god!
Go back!
Okay give me a sec.
I'll go back.
I'm gonna go back.
Don't worry!
Coming back!
I'm coming back I guess.
Wait!
Oh my god!
He's actually loyal?
He loyal?
That's crazy!
In my Three Kingdoms era?
Oh my god guys.
It's very hard to find loyal men in the Three Kingdoms area.
Like someone that's not gonna betray?
That's crazy.
Unheard of.
Jesus Christ.
How am I still fighting?
There's like one or two people that broke in.
I like how he said that but like two people broke in already.
It's not my fault though guys.
I tried my best.
Guys, it's not my fault that they broke in, okay?
Like, I'm just one guy.
Alright, here we go.
If he's so honorable, why he fucking work with Cao Cao, huh?
That's right.
To be fair, I never cared about, I never cared about Tai Chi because I never, I didn't like his design.
It wasn't...
Look.
Look, all I'm saying was that younger me younger me was like was only interested on the people that
uh...
Wait, did I mistook Tai Chi with Zhu Hong?
Did I?
Wait, wasn't he with Wu?
Wasn't he blue?
Or was he green?
I don't remember.
Oh my god!
They're running to kill him!
Shit, where's the ladder?
Oh, he's red!
Oh my god.
Okay, wait, how did he get to red?
Okay guys, I need to go save him.
He was red all along?
Okay, his design was so uninteresting that I didn't even remember which faction he joined.
That was how...
That was how uninteresting he was to me.
That's how I like don't even remember what faction he was in.
He was red all along.
I didn't even realize he was red all... Where is this guy?
Oh my god, where...
Oh, there he is.
Oh, you guys were like 1 HP.
How the fuck did you break in?
What?
Manny!
I didn't...
Are you fucking serious?
Where?
Which is sub?
Which is... Which gate?
Is it this gate?
Oh my god.
Which gate was it?
Was it this one?
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
Okay, we won't deal with the people inside, I guess.
That's fine.
But yeah, I never cared much about his design, because it was never...
It wasn't that interesting to me.
Okay, let's deal with this real quick, I guess.
I don't know.
I didn't think you would...
I didn't think it would happen!
Okay.
Alright, we're just killing this guy real quick, and then I'll help out with the rest.
Don't worry, I'm...
What?
Where?
Where is he?
Okay.
I... I'm trying not... I'm trying my best!
There's so many forces!
How did they all break in?!
Okay.
Done.
Alright.
We got this guy.
That's fine.
That's fine!
It's okay!
I believe!
I can't believe they just climbed the ladder like that!
It's just two men!
Oh my god, we gotta get him out of here!
Oh please, PC!
Peace!
Please, please, please live!
Please live!
Please fucking live!
I wanna prove that I'm a true warrior!
Oh my god, please!
Oh my god, I have to make sure everybody is alive!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Arrow time.
Do it, dragons!
For Toki!
Shoot your arrows!
This is serious.
Ooh.
Who challenged me?
Who was it?
Okay, it's too late.
It's too late.
Look, I would have loved to challenge you, but like, you're too late, son.
You're a little too late.
Okay, nice.
Okay, we kill this guy, and then, oh my god!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Please, just let me kill him!
Please, just live a little longer!
Please, I need to kill him!
Okay, okay, I'm coming back!
I'm coming over!
Oh my god!
Please, don't die!
You're literally the only Genoa left!
Please, I'm heading over!
Please don't die!
Please, ICG, please don't die!
Okay, okay!
Alright,
there we go.
It's fine.
It's okay!
We're okay!
Guanyin's here!
Guanyin's here, it's okay!
Let's go!
This is a very important fight!
Holy shit!
Yo, what the fuck?
What's going on?!
Jesus Christ!
Okay!
Okay, let's do that again!
Yeah, that's not broken at all, guys!
Boom!
Where did he- oh, we did it!
Behold, the god of war!
I did it, guys!
All of me!
Random self-insert man did all of that!
Yippee!
They're finally gone for real!
Just Guanyin!
But yeah, I never- I don't say I don't like Taishi.
I just never acknowledge his existence.
After one, perform this move just as your cover wheel increases the number of wheels being- Oh wait, I wanna do that!
That sounds fucking sick!
Guanyin casually creates a black hole.
Loki is our Oshi.
Increase this amount of stability plus four- Yay!
Oh my god, look at everything I completed!
Nice.
I'm braver now.
Let's get- Oh, I don't have anything else.
Just Guanyin things, yeah.
I did it, guys!
All of me!
Why is he wearing blue?
Is he gonna be red?
What?
Forcefully?
How would I fight with determination if I was forced to do it?
Is that purple?
It looks blue.
Yeah.
Yeah, after everything you did.
What?
Alright, nice.
We did it.
What?
You and Shao?
The fuck was I doing with you and Shao?
Nobody knows how to pronounce Conrong's name, right?
I don't either.
Which was like yesterday.
Guys, good to see you.
I'm so popular.
I hope we can fight together again someday.
But I wonder when that will be.
I serve Lord Liu Yao now.
But it seems he does not trust me.
What?
You look so trustable.
If only he knew you're- Yeah, I'm sliding in.
I'm glad to hear that you deem my skills adequate.
But it is only natural to deny a newcomer's important tasks.
I do not fault Lord Liu Yao's judgment.
I have made somewhat of a name for myself on the battlefield.
But I have yet to accomplish anything in his service.
You will have to earn his respect, little by little.
Eventually, he will trust me with more important tasks.
And I will be rewarded accordingly.
That is what I believe.
The thought is more than enough.
I think it's worth a reward of its own.
That's it.
I am just the thing.
I have finished my tasks for today.
What will you give to my team?
To pay for everything for all that you've done.
Let this one be on me.
Then it's settled.
Don't let me catch you holding back just because- Now?
Have some food.
Why do all the generals just treat me out for food?
Like, there's other stuff to do.
Isn't there not- Is there not anything else to do in ancient China?
Like...
Being with you gives me strength, not doki.
I'm lucky to have a friend like you of whom I can speak in such a carefree manner.
Ah, yes.
Friend.
Let's continue to better ourselves.
So that we can live through this chaotic time.
I don't understand.
Why is it all just- It's always food!
Why can't it be anything else?
Okay, I want to do the...
Uh, okay.
This one cancels it.
This one does the- What was the one that was super cool?
Oh, this one.
Flying Spirit Wave.
There we go.
That's the one I wanted to do.
That one looked cool.
That one looked cool as hell.
Okay.
It's always food.
More than just food.
Is this a village?
Okay, there's the village.
I want to go here to see.
The way to a man's heart is through his stomach.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Let's see.
What is...
Interactions.
Uh, yeah, I'll pay for this one.
Dianwei Yang Province.
Alright.
Time to do our favorite, guys.
It's time to visit...
Dianwei, wherever he is.
Where the fuck does he live?
Oh, it's right here.
Oh, there he is.
Hello.
I totally authentically created...
Completed your training, sir.
I swear to god, if he's gonna invite me to food again.
What are you doing?
Oh.
That's me.
Yes, southern.
He got a southern accent in ancient China.
I am the same as those yellow turbans.
Lord Cao Cao ignored my past, took me in, and gave me his trust.
He...
He was on a boat to the New World.
Dianwei was on that boat to the New World and founded Texas.
China is huge, okay?
He was patient zero of Texas.
What the fuck are you shopping for?
That you...
What are we buying?
Pots?
The first Texan.
Oh my god, it's always food!
A bite, you say?
Oh yeah, no, he's definitely in it for the brisket.
Alright, nice.
My bond with him grows stronger.
Where's the village?
Where the fuck...
Oh, it's here.
It's like... here?
Oh, here.
Oh, it's like my...
my secret area.
My little secret hidey hole.
Alright, my personal doctor that does not pay for rent at all and lives with me.
What do you think?
What?
Yeah, watch this.
I did it.
That's not me, right?
I didn't do it.
Hehehe.
No, no, I'm a casual.
Wait,
oh wait, he was a real person?
Oh my god, he was real this entire time?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he actually has a name.
Bai... who the fuck is Bai Luan?
I'm an outsider.
Wait, are they dead?
Oh my god, I'm...
I'm from the Creed.
This is my Assassin's Creed, guys.
I'm literally from... I'm literally...
My ancestor, Altair.
This was Assassin's Creed all along.
What?
He's a chief?
He's 10!
Who gave this 10 year old power?
He's not the emperor.
Hahahaha.
He's not the fucking emperor.
Damn,
I can't believe it.
They saw the emperor was 10 years old so they did the same thing.
I just saw...
What the fuck?
Oh my... my controller doesn't work.
My controller stopped working.
Oh, I was just getting...
I was just getting herb incensed up again.
So all I have to do is just get incensed up.
A scent of an herb?
Oh no.
Oh my god.
So how do I know if my visions are real or if I'm just really, really high?
What?
It's the tinkers of herbs.
Is that what you're saying?
I can't believe it.
The doctor wants me to get the doctor wants me to get even more herbed up.
What's that?
Oh my god, my controller is back.
Okay guys, I fixed it.
I fixed my controller.
I need 50.
I don't have that.
What even is my bravery gauge?
Is that my battle arts?
Yeah, is that my battle arts?
Yeah.
You were raised?
Why was he so short?
He was shorter than me.
Wait, Faya is the same age as me?
Who taught you?
The true short king.
That's why he's still a chief.
I killed a lot of people.
I don't know if you can live through that.
The only way I can get through the day is when you light up the incense.
See?
Oh, you wanna talk?
We just- We live together.
Um...
Oh,
I hope- Alright.
We're gonna test all- Okay.
Let's see what doesn't kill me.
The human experimentation tab.
I heard there's some rare specimens to be- We're gonna freestyle it, guys.
Let's just eat all the random mushrooms in the field.
To be found in Yang Province.
If you see any of your travels, can you bring them to me?
Okay.
I'm so excited.
Yeah.
Chance.
Not that I saw you sitting outside the building.
Of course.
Not really.
I have to eat random herbs that my personal doctor's gonna cook.
Who I think is actually a child.
You are no one.
So you can yet be someone.
You can be someone, and yet you are still no one.
The fuck?
Are you spe- Are you- Are you speaking in real?
As good a question as any.
What my words mean depends entirely on the choices before you.
What I'm saying will become clear eventually.
You'll get it sooner or later.
I'll have my eye on you to see how you progress, too.
The incense is hitting hard right now.
This ritual retreat is open for people like yourself, you know?
No, I don't know.
I don't- What the fuck was that interaction?
Okay, okay, he's assigning me a mission.
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
Dramatic success with a tactic.
Once achieved, activate tactics from a wheel recovery?
The fuck is wheel recovery?
Am I gonna have to pay for you, too?
Oh my god.
I feel like I'm gonna have to pay for this guy as well.
What's my objective?
Ciao, ciao.
Lupe.
The fuck is Jen?
Is Jen she- she at the red?
Is that for Redman?
Okay, Chen Gong Chao Chao wants to talk.
Like, I don't wanna talk.
I don't- I don't wanna- I don't wanna join Wu.
Wait, is it- Is that part of it?
Oh, it is.
Okay, what does Chen Gong wanna say?
I think it's wonderful.
Hey, you're blue now!
Wait, was he always blue?
I know he's gonna be blue.
Yeah, he's blue before he's purple.
Before he's gonna be Erpa.
Oh.
Bro, I'm like, he's not here to glaze right now.
Why are you glazing Chao Chao up?
That's it?
The fuck?
He just wanted to meet up to glaze- He just- He just wanted to meet up and glaze him.
Like, what?
You made me come all the way here just for that?
Bro.
That's fucked.
That's so fucked.
Can't believe you made me travel all the way for that.
Show on map.
Yeah, show this on map.
Where is it on the map?
Doctor!
I told you to show it on the map!
Wait, there's an- Wait, there's a guy that's like, question mark.
Oh, it shows on the mini map.
Oh, I see.
I was like, what the fuck?
I was ready for you to show it.
Okay, I have to meet an- A character that's like, question- Oh, there he is.
I don't know how I've missed that guy, but I'll talk to him too.
Are there some ra- Oh, it's Yang Province.
Okay, who are you?
Oh!
You're one of the newer ones!
AHHHHHH!
Oh my
- Oh my god, oh my god it's him!
AHHHH!
I don't care about you!
Get out, get out!
Get out!
I don't...
I don't care... I don't care, I don't care...
AHHHH!
Oh my god, wait, where's your mustache?
Wait, no, nevermind...
I don't care anymore.
He doesn't have his mustache.
Okay, well it is intriguing to meet a guardian of peace in the flesh.
I've heard that you have lost all your memories.
Where's Stache?
How unfortunate.
Where is mustache?
Where is it?
What happened?
Why did you shave?
Why?
Chugal young is more knowledgeable than anyone I know, but his behavior is somewhat unconventional and You on the other hand are always downplaying your extraordinary intelligence.
Don't care about him.
He is does not matter I find it quite vexing Anyway, where's your mustache?
You were almost perfect!
You looked so good everywhere else, but the no mustache just kills it.
Sorry about all that.
Why did you shave?
My eyes are not quite as sharp.
Ah, the wonder they only showed the backside.
So there is something I wish to ask you.
No wonder.
Which of the major lords has impressed you the most?
Lord Lube.
I thought so.
I also feel that there's something.
He's young.
He can always grow.
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
That's enough for now, Shishu.
You're so right guys.
You shouldn't ask questions.
You're so right.
You've already decided the answer to.
Guys, you're so right.
I can certainly understand your sentiment.
However, for Lord Lube to achieve conquest, he will have to walk a long and perilous path.
That's why I want to help him.
Although perhaps... I'm not paying attention to this conversation.
Thank you.
Your words of encouragement mean a lot.
I don't care about Shishu.
I don't have the opportunity to speak again soon.
They shamed all the good ones.
Where is he?
No, I don't want to talk to you!
I want to talk to Jucatlan!
Give me Jucatlan!
Give it to me!
I don't care about you!
I don't care.
Where is he?
Okay, I'm gonna... I'm going back home.
I'm replaying that cutscene.
Where did he go?
Where is he?
Wait, where's the cutscene?
I can't even replay that!
Oh, oh, oh, there's TauTau.
Okay, here we go.
Where is he?
Is it this?
No.
Where is he?
What do you mean?
Oh, it's in records?
Oh, okay.
Wait, where?
Wait, why do I... why is it just...
It's Bonds?
Where is he?
How do I...
How do I watch it?
Is it his Bond?
No, it's not.
It's not.
Oh, it's Zushu's Bond?
Where is he?
Okay, I'm ready.
I got it ready.
Okay.
Nice to meet you.
I don't care.
Oh my god.
No!
There you go.
Oh, okay.
Yay!
You're so much hotter now!
Oh, no!
No!
Okay, I'm okay now.
I'm okay now.
I'm alright now.
I'm happy now.
I got what I wanted.
It does look better!
It looks so much better with my mustache!
It does!
I'm okay now.
I'm happy.
I'm happy now.
Yippee!
That's all it takes.
That's all it takes for me.
Okay, Yang Province.
I should find it here.
I should find the herb.
Or whatever here.
Where the fuck is this herb I have to find?
Is it here?
No, that's the old clay.
Oh, it might be this.
There you go.
I found it!
I did it!
Okay, he wanted one anyway, so...
I'll take it back here.
I got it!
Alright, time to test it.
It'll make incense out of it right away.
Why don't we try the scent in the village?
Let's go there now!
Alright, let's go to the village!
Let's go!
Let's take that incense!
Wait, how do I go to the village again?
Is it here?
Oh, it's here.
Alright, head to the village.
Gah!
Marsha, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Such a shame Connor Hall never became a king.
It would have been so funny.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Reg, thank you for the super chat!
I got to grow a mustache now for no reason in particular.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Yo, Ayo and my homie!
You and Ha!
And get that incense out in the abandoned village!
Let's go!
Ayo and my child doctor!
It has not fucking hit purity yet.
But we grew up together.
I feel like this playthrough...
This particular part has been the most progress we've ever made.
Game-wise.
We've actually been in so many battles to progress.
I heard there was another rebellion down south.
Only one fate awaits those who oppose the Han.
The leaders of these rebellions must be aware of this.
How could they not be?
But there is a reason they are so determined to act.
Soon it will be our turn to play our roles.
Ah, what do you mean we?
Where are you?
Ziluan, are you ready?
It's a role you should know well.
What the fuck do you mean we?
The Han Dynasty is collapsing.
Discontent is rife.
Enemies within and without plot its demise.
It cannot go on.
Something must give.
The time will come when we must risk our lives and fulfill our roles as the guardians of peace.
Ziluan, listen.
When that time comes, you and Zhuhua will become my wings.
We did this together.
Yippee!
They say as I only see him when the incense goes hard.
A duty you would give your life to fulfill.
You were listening?
What were you doing while I was in my fucking trance?
I mean, what good are you to your duty or anyone else if you end up dying?
When he lived, my father was lauded as a saint.
But now that he's gone, nobody so much as speaks his name.
But I suppose we all have our own way of doing things.
Who am I to say what the correct way is?
Still, I wonder what Bai Luman was trying to achieve.
The title Guardian of Peace sounds grand, sure.
But what exactly do you- I killed Lu Bu!
What the fuck do you mean?
You were there!
That should be enough to show you what my duty was.
Like, what was your job, Doki?
What was your purpose?
I'm like, what the fuck do you- I killed Lu- What more do you want from me?
What the fuck more do you want?
It's been snooping around.
Yeah.
You didn't save Sun Jian.
Doesn't need a key to restoring your memories.
Good, then we'll try to try some other scents as well.
I heard there's a rare herb that can be found in Jing Promise.
It's apparently called Moongrass.
Oh no, gonna hit the good stuff.
I can't make the next incense without it.
Okay, it is in...
What was it in?
Okay, let's just talk to Lu Bei.
I don't want to...
I don't want to get addicted.
Let's go talk to him.
Guys, we gotta make sure we don't get addicted here.
Okay, where is the Lu Bei?
Oh, it's this way.
We gotta make sure we...
We, like, take it in, like...
And, like, back in, like...
What's the word called?
Make sure we don't take it too much.
Okay, you have become unable to assist or join any faction you have not made you wish to proceed.
Yeah.
Yeah, moderation.
Yeah, we are doing moderation, guys.
What about his dad?
Oh my god, no!
Oh my god, the random gossip in ancient China in this random village.
How did you find out about it?
I feel like villagers back then...
It's really hard to hear these rumors because they're like...
There's no phones or like...
And a lot of them can't read.
So it's like...
How did you find out, Mr. Random fucking villager?
How did he find out?
I guess merchants and traders.
You're right.
Yeah, but it also takes a long time to travel.
Speak, pretty boy.
Position.
A position strong enough to seek to conquer the entire realm.
I take it you are prepared to do so?
I am.
This time, your father is dead.
Now grow a mustache.
And history will tell.
To become the true father.
That is why I have gathered the wisest and bravest in the land.
And Diaochan.
And Dianwei.
Sorry, Dianwei.
I was like, I've gathered the wisest and most intelligent and then we have like...
Big southern man there.
Well, it feels great to have a clear objective.
We are about to embark on the path.
Dianwei is the brave one.
What he says is right.
And yet...
Whoa.
He's already scheming!
Oh my god.
He's scheming already.
I am deeply grateful for your help.
I need to thank you properly.
Yeah, did not get textured.
You can tell they did not spend time texturing him.
His texture compared to Lu Bei is actually crazy.
But the fact is, I need you to lend me your strength again.
My strength?
Yes, Tao Qian, governor of Shu province, is in peril.
Would you go to his aid?
Lord Tao Qian, has something happened in Shu?
Were you aware...
I don't think he realized he's not the main character, guys.
Yes, I had heard.
Upon receiving his appointment, he invited his father, Lord Cao Song, to his province.
On the way, Lord Cao Song stopped at Lord Tao Qian's residence.
And there, he died under suspicious circumstances.
No.
Cao Cao, believing Lord Tao Qian was to blame, ordered his troops to ravage Shu.
But Lord Tao Qian is a man of integrity.
I cannot imagine him doing anything like that.
How would you know?
There's so many assassinations almost every day.
I, too, have often heard...
That he is a good man.
He could be spreading those rumors.
Clearly, who's gonna fact check the internet that hasn't been invented yet?
I expect he would try to...
I can literally spread rumors in ancient China.
People will believe it.
But...
It appears he has neglected to do so.
Who's gonna fact check me?
XD
Oh, what the fuck do you mean?
Yes, they are.
You don't know about dolphins, guys.
Lord Liu Bei, please, go to the aid of Lord Tao Qian.
Save my friend and the people of Shu.
Lord Kong Zhong.
Alright, Liu Bei, come.
Now we're back here.
So, you accepted his request, then?
There is never a dull moment with you, brother.
Still, why would Lord Cao Cao take such a drastic step?
I don't know.
What I do know is that Lord Cao Cao scares me.
I can't shake the feeling that if we're not careful, we may become his next target.
I mean, he was pretty scary back then.
There is some noble purpose behind this brutal invasion.
Yet, no matter how one attempts to justify it, the fact remains that he is perpetrating a heinous act.
Although, I suppose one could argue this is why I am a less worthy man than him.
I am always too idealistic.
No, not in my eyes, at least, brother.
I fully agree with you.
Following the most righteous path does not always lead to virtue.
There are times when virtue comes from following the path of the greater good.
Quan Yu.
Quan Yu, don't enable him.
Well, I don't know, sir, but one thing I do know, I won't stand for such brutality.
Don't enable him.
He's gonna be a fucking joke.
And I'm gonna- From Dao Tower or anyone else.
I'm gonna be the one enabling him.
You can only follow your own heart.
Whatever path you choose, we, your sworn brothers, will do our best to pave the way.
You don't need to enable him.
I'll be there to do it for you guys.
Oh nice, okay.
Mission available.
Rescue the village.
Okay, so we gotta do...
Is this the green side?
Zombie green.
Okay, I'm gonna start.
Wait, actually, let's talk to- Oh, let's talk to him first.
Hello, Xun Yu.
Hello.
What a pleasure meeting you here.
Wow.
You seem to be getting along so well with Lord Xun Yu.
I was hoping to get a chance to talk with you myself.
You're getting jealous?
Getting along?
Well, he is always bringing up a conversation.
That's me!
I would be grateful.
He's jealous!
If I could grow closer to you as well.
Oh my God.
Let me tell you about what I've been doing.
Oh my God, he is jealous.
I was observing how things are among the people in town.
To ascertain what role the government should play here.
It's like, how dare you?
I saw her first.
Warfare alone is not enough to clear a path forward for our leader.
He wants in, yeah.
That is why I spend my free time walking the streets like this.
Uh, no one- Your enthusiasm is admirable.
Your praise is most welcome.
But I am merely carrying out my responsibilities in the service of our leader.
By the way, may I ask you something personal?
Sure!
What do you want to ask?
You have yet to pledge your allegiance to any specific lord.
Oh, that's awkward.
Might you consider putting your towns to use...
Oh, that's so awkward.
...among our ranks under Lord Cao Cao's command?
That's really awkward, buddy.
Yeah, um, I haven't decided yet.
If I don't understand, it is not a simple decision.
But you are a guardian of peace.
Yeah, about that.
Don't worry, it can be forbidden.
That makes it harder, right?
But it may be your intention to continue to drift across the land like a benevolent breeze, helping as many people as you can.
But you're just explaining, Lu Bei.
But you must understand that allying with those walking opposing paths is no different than allying with none at all.
It will accomplish nothing and will instead further fan the flames of conflict.
No one wishes for that.
These are my thoughts on the matter.
Our land should be governed by one capable leader.
And that leader can be none other than Lord Cao Cao.
Oh, that's so awkward.
It is he who will lead us on the path to peace.
When he finds out in two minutes.
Do you not also wish to see what then?
To the chaos that plagues the land?
I would not presume to force an answer from you at this moment.
But please do consider my proposal.
Don't worry, I'll think about it.
That is all I wish to discuss with you for now.
But would you do me the honor of visiting me at my estate?
Wait, what?
I would like to foster a friendship between us.
As men who share a similar fate.
Wait, at your house?
We can do it out here.
Wait, why are you a prick?
Oh, fade to black.
Okay, that sounds right.
That fade to black.
Yep.
That.
All right.
Oh, man.
That's so awkward.
That.
Yep.
Whoops.
Sorry, Taochun.
Sorry.
I know I just visited your house and everything, but...
Sorry, buddy.
I'm sorry.
Look, I...
Look, Lupe has Guan Yun, okay?
Oh, it's you.
I heard you rode out to aid Lord Taochun.
And I guess Zhao Yun, too.
They have, like, all the best characters.
As you can see, I brought extra troops.
Courtesy of Lord Gongsun Zhang.
Fucking Lupe sucks.
This is my chance to repay the debt I incurred at Jieshao.
My spear is at your service.
Now this is a fine ally to have at my side.
Like, Taochun just has, like, Xiaodun.
That's it.
I
can't believe Dynasty Warriors has given us a game where...
Zhou Yu has so...
Where Zhao Yun has so little screen time.
That's absolutely insane to me.
How little screen time Zhao Yun has.
Taochun's forces are marching on to your missions to stop them.
We, of course, want to protect Lord Taochun from Cao Cao's army.
But at the same time, we cannot afford for me to fall into his clutches.
Brother, are you finally realizing how important you are?
Uh, I don't want it to be a distraction, but I suppose I need to be protected.
But be that as it may, the army they have gathered is truly immense.
It's risky to face their attacks head-on, and we simply try to hold our position.
We will be overwhelmed in short order.
Then we should act first to break their momentum.
I agree.
If we hit by assaults from the north and the south in particular, we will never be able to hold the lines.
Then we shall split up and meet the advances separately.
I will take the position in the front of the castle and dig in against their central assault.
Remember, the enemy will outnumber us.
Any retreat will be fraught with danger.
Worry that we hold the line with the castle at our backs.
We'll hold them back and seize whatever opportunity presents itself.
That seems to be our only option.
Sounds like we're leaving a lot.
Oh, yeah.
Nope, that's...
You might have to wonder, where are our strategists?
While Taotao has like six of them at the table, we have like, I guess, just Lu Bei making the strategies right now.
It's a little awkward.
We don't really have any strategies, guys.
Not yet.
Zero strategies versus six.
I believe our str...
Look, Lu Bei is like, unga bunga strength time before Zhuge Liang comes in here.
Of course, Zhang Fei is into that.
Yeah, my spear as well.
I'll not let you down.
Oh, I can... let's get Zhao Yun in here for like one time.
I don't know how...
He's not that strong compared to Guan Yu, but like, let's give him a bone.
Alright, let's go here.
Oh, fuck.
No, I went the wrong way.
Let's go.
I meant here.
That's where I meant to go, guys.
Wait, let me see if there's any objective I have to do.
Uh...
If there's anyone that I really need to do.
Launch, activate dramatic success, win five duels, win one duel, defeat 50 foes, sword attack.
Uh...
Sword attack, gauntlet, wheel recovery, pull it out.
None of them are ones that I want to do anything with though, so I don't really care too much.
Fuck it, let's just use the...
Fuck it, none of them are ones that I actually care much about.
So we're just gonna fight.
Okay, nice.
That's right!
Easy!
Oh, Zhao Yun's dragon flash is one of the best?
Fucking course it is.
Not the god of war.
I shall meet the enemy's attack here.
We may be at a grave disadvantage, but I have faith in my men.
All right, let's get...
Oh, Zhao Yun!
Get over here!
No way!
I got you!
The weaker of the brothers!
Or the cousins!
I keep losing track of these two melony relatives.
Don't worry, I got you!
I'll kill the first cousin!
There you go.
Get out!
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Don't worry!
I'm killing the people that actually do matter in his army!
It'll be fine!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, um, that's awkward.
That's awkward.
Oh, no!
Let me just kill Zhao Yun now!
I swear to god, I'm gonna save you guys!
I swear to god!
Oh, no!
They're heading over!
I swear to god!
Just let me kill him first and then I'll come over!
Jesus Christ.
No, not Zhao Yun!
Step aside, I literally just killed you!
All right, we gotta go help.
We gotta...
Oh, this is awkward.
Oh, this is so awkward.
Oh, no!
I'm running!
Oh!
Okay, don't worry!
I'm coming over!
Oh!
Oh, my god!
Oh, why are they all dying so fast?
Oh, gosh!
Don't worry!
I'm coming over!
Oh, we have zero morale!
Please!
I swear to god!
I can do this!
Eat your buns!
Please!
Please, don't stop!
Stop, guys!
Yes, you can!
I'm here!
I'm literally here!
I'm literally here, guys!
We can do this!
Guys, I'm literally here!
We can totally do this!
Guys, we can totally...
Guys!
Guys, please!
We can do this, guys!
Just believe!
Oh, god!
Okay, um...
Okay, we gotta defeat...
Okay, let's...
Let's figure this out.
This is a little awkward because there's a lot of them.
So, um...
I gotta be angry real fast.
Give me a sec.
Let me be angry real...
Real...
Real fast.
Okay, there we go.
This should be fine, right?
Jesus Christ!
There's so many people!
Oh my god!
I'm trying my best here!
Please!
We need just a little bit more of...
Now and beyond.
Do your thing, Dianne!
Okay, nice.
Okay, we did it.
Oh my god!
Our morale never went up, but it's okay.
We still did it.
That's okay, guys.
Wait, I got...
I got Zhao Yun's lance!
Nice.
The morale meter did not budge.
It's okay.
We don't...
We don't need it.
My presence is strong enough, right?
Oh, is this Zhanfei's weapon?
Oh, never mind.
This is Zhanfei's weapon.
How is there so many?
It's okay.
We're almost there!
We did it, guys!
Oh, all the other generals are dead.
But we did it!
Oh, no.
We still did it, guys!
Where are we going?
No, it's not!
Lu Bei, they're all dead!
What do you mean, Lu Bei?
They're all dead!
Lu Bei's group has me and my army of three.
Where the fuck do we go?
Oh, no.
I gotta go downstairs.
There's so many fights!
Lu Bei, the master strategist.
Oh, no.
He still has two eyes, too, guys!
Guys, he still has two eyes!
What do I do?
That's fucking right.
Oh, that's all I did on him.
I'm sorry!
Oh, you definitely care.
Don't lie!
Oh, my god!
No!
Is this a breakup?
Oh, he's breaking up with me!
I'm sorry!
You're literally...
You and Zheng Liao are the only cool ones!
I'm sorry!
Oh, no.
Zhao Yun.
Eat your bread!
I'm sorry!
I can't believe it!
He broke up with us, guys!
With us!
It was a group effort!
I'm so sad.
I can't believe it.
It's still not up, guys.
Our morale is still fucked up.
My team still does not believe.
Toki, you broke his neck!
Yeah, but he started it!
He broke up with us, guys!
First!
It had to be done!
Oh, my god.
My generals actually fought back?
Okay, nice.
Okay, I need you guys...
I need more of the people that die around me here.
Where are they?
There they are.
It's going by pretty...
There's so many horses!
Wait, where is that?
Where's Guanyin?
Oh, shit!
He's over there.
Okay, Guanyin, I'll come back very soon.
Let me just grab this base real fast.
We're almost there!
This base is almost ours!
Nice!
Don't worry, Guanyin.
I'm coming over!
Guanyin!
You can't die like this!
You're literally a god of war!
All units!
Commence the charge!
Oh, my god!
Guys!
Okay, he was fine.
Wait, I must kill steal this real fast.
Oh,
my god!
We did it!
Oh, my god!
Lupe, I don't know what you're trying to do, Lupe!
Jesus!
Do it here!
Lupe does not got this and you know it!
You guys fucking know this!
Jesus Christ!
Oh, my god!
What is going on?!
Stop it, please!
There's so many things!
Oh, no!
Wait, how do I prevent that?
Wait, how?
How do I prevent it?
How do I prevent it?!
I don't have enough...
Oh, my god!
How do I prevent?!
Guys, I don't have...
Okay.
Oh, my god!
No!
I still can't think!
Yoink!
No, he's killed!
Stop!
Okay.
Okay, I got this.
Okay, guys, guys, I got this this time.
Guys, guys, that was like really rough, but I'm okay now.
I'm okay now.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll be fine.
I'll be fine now.
I'm not gonna use any of my battle arts until he does his thing.
I'm gonna wait until he does his thing before I use a battle art.
I've learned my lesson.
I learned my lesson.
It's fine, I have enough.
Oh, my god!
Everything is...
All right, there we go!
We got it!
I have something better than the palm!
Watch this!
Did I do it?
There we go!
Guys, I didn't do it.
Okay, let me...
It looks like I didn't do it, guys.
Where is he?
Where's the head?
Wait, where is he?
Oh, my god, there he is.
There he is.
There we go!
We did it!
Oh, my god!
Get close and do it!
Oh, I did it!
Holy shit!
It's so hard!
Get over here!
Oh, I did it!
Jesus Christ!
We did it!
Oh, my god!
Lupe versus Cao Cao!
Okay.
That's fine.
It's fine, we just kill him.
I almost have enough for Zhou Yu, don't worry!
Again?!
Oh, my...
Fine.
Fine!
I'll do your shit, Cao Cao!
Jesus Christ!
I'm trying my best!
Oh, my god!
Change!
Okay.
Rage!
I'm not jumping!
They just keep doing it!
I swear to god, I am not jumping!
I literally can't move!
I wish I could move, but I can't!
Who am I attacking?
Like, okay, good.
Okay.
Thank god.
I am so fucked up.
Oh, my god!
Okay, there you go!
This has to be it!
Yes!
I got one HP!
We did it!
Oh, we did it!
That's so scary!
Oh, my god!
More than HP!
I don't know, dream!
I literally just killed you!
He's like, I will never retreat!
JK, bye!
What is just...
Have we won?
Yay!
Oh god, that was so rough!
That was incredibly rough!
I will not retreat unless...
29.
Yay, Furt, you did it!
Okay, nice, I got that.
Okay, uh...
Definitely want more defense.
Yep, that was very rough for me.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, wait, I can!
Okay, I have the bravery here.
I was gonna say I forgot about this.
What the fuck?
Wait, that's so strong!
I won't buy it yet, though.
I don't have enough.
I'm like, too broke.
We did it!
That's just straight...
Magic in my Dynasty Warriors game!
How fucking dare they?
Truly, by a Most Grateful.
Lord Liu Bei, you are a beacon in this turbulent world.
An immoral scoundrel like Cao Cao has no hope of defeating a noble man like yourself.
Immoral, you say?
I wonder if Lord Cao Cao has ever considered whether his actions are moral or righteous.
Hmm?
What do you mean?
I mean, I have fought alongside Lord Cao Cao many times, and neither righteousness nor greed drive him.
Instead, only one thing rules his heart.
Pure reason.
When he set out to avenge his father's death, I am certain it wasn't rage or grief that drove him to mobilize his army.
And now, he marches to take the land of Shu.
Not because it is just or unjust...
Okay, Liu Bei, I don't trust anything you say anymore.
Your strategy for that entire run was that maybe we can do it from Shu because we're strong.
I don't know.
I didn't realize you held him in such esteem.
Perhaps I should rethink my opinion of our enemy.
We got this, guys!
We are strong.
And you were surprised when we won.
Was he wrong?
If I wasn't in that war, I don't think they would have won.
And then they have the audacity to write me out of history?
That's quite an honor.
Sure.
Pretty sure the heavens are looking at Guanyin.
Turned it down?
Has he gone mad?
He finally had a chance to move up in the world.
He said it was too big a responsibility for someone like him without suitable aspirations.
Or something like that.
Aspirations, eh?
Well, they must be something special for him to turn down a whole province.
But then, what is Tao Chen going to do about Shu?
Yeah.
I'll take it.
Yeah, I'll take it.
Hello, I'm here.
I'm here.
Hello.
I want to govern.
Wait, I want to...
No, I'm here too!
You guys want to ask for my opinion?
Fucked up.
He's literally having this conversation in front of me.
You don't count!
Like, they're having this fucking conversation in front of me and they're like, Anyway!
Sucks that no one else wants to govern.
Oh, hey, Taoyuan.
I thought you had a crush on Lupe.
Why are you here?
Thank you.
I know.
I'm just a beat up NPC to them.
Jesus Christ.
Sup?
I'm thinking about...
Well, I am joining.
Yeah, I'm thinking about it.
He's like, good, at least it's not forbidden now.
I can't do that.
Not with my honor.
Wait!
What?
What do you mean by that?
Oh, he's backtracking.
He's like, I don't think you will.
Oh, I mean...
I mean...
No, I meant...
Yeah, no, no, no, no, no.
Sure, bro.
Backtrack.
He's like, oh, he's talking to me like that.
No, I meant...
I'm sorry, that's not what I mean.
All right.
Wow.
What the fuck?
Jesus Christ.
How many?
Oh my god.
I have so many letters.
Jesus.
Okay.
So many letters from all my suitors, guys.
He has been traveling with you for some time now, hasn't he?
I visited him once while you were away at battle.
He looked to be very busy picking herbs and boiling them to prepare some kind of decoction.
No, I believe it was more like an incense of some sort.
The smell was dreadful and smoke filled the air, but he didn't seem to mind.
His desire to cure patients must give him strength to ensure such hardship when faced with medical issues to solve.
He loses sight of all else.
It's not a place to make such requests, but please take good care of the doctor and take this all as well.
I hope you give me something good for both of you.
All right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, anonymous soldier.
Another Dragoon super chat.
Much time has passed since we met.
I rather not mention my name, but I was once part of the volunteer army and now I fight for Lord Lupe.
You saved my life and I'm writing this letter to thank you properly.
Ever since we began marching together as volunteers, I've been impressed by your every move.
One day I was watching you in battle when an enemy officer's blade appeared before my eyes.
I couldn't move, but you rushed over and the officer was gone in a blink of an eye.
That wasn't the only time either.
You saved me time and time again.
I want nothing more than to gaze upon you from afar to see where your path takes you.
We will meet again one day.
I'm sure of it.
Thank you for the super chat, anonymous soldier.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, what does Xiaohudun want to say?
Can I convince you to fight for Cao Cao?
I'm sure that you're already aware of our invasion into Shu province.
Oh, that was a little too late, Xiaohudun.
Whoops.
Oopsie, did not read his letter in time.
I read it for too late.
Whoops.
All right, we'll read the other letters another time.
There's too many, too many letters.
Did not age you well.
After all the work I put in to open this shop.
I left him on read.
I'd be in tears if it got burned down in a bottle.
Whoops, my bad.
What's this?
Shop, okay.
Is there any better?
Okay, let's see.
I want to see if there's any of my bonds.
Oh, it's you.
All right, champ Xiaohudun.
Zhuge Liang, Zhuge Liang, Zhuge Liang, Zhuge Liang, Zhuge Liang, Zhuge Liang.
Guys, we gotta... we have someone very important to talk to.
I didn't see what province he was in.
I have to find it myself.
There he is.
Hey, has something happened to Lord Sun Jian?
Where is he?
Wait, where is he?
Oh my god, don't tell me he's over there.
No, he's not.
I'm checking.
He's over here.
Be careful when you venture outside of the city.
Where is he?
Where are you?
I'm trying...
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
Hello?
Hello, Zhuge Liang.
Oh, there you are.
Perfect timing.
I have a favor to ask for you.
In recent weeks, a piece of my fields has been shattered.
I want you to see that it's re-established.
I'll make it worth your while.
I'm not so brazen to ask a man to fight for free on my behalf.
Don't worry, I'll do anything for you.
No questions asked.
Don't worry, I'm here.
Don't worry, I got you!
For Zhuge Liang!
That's what you get.
You think you can kill me?
You don't understand how far I will go for him.
Okay, he's a little strong for a bandit.
Not gonna lie.
This guy should join an army.
This guy- This guy should join an army.
What the fuck?
How is he so strong?
You might as well be in the army with that fucking strength.
Oh wait, it's because he's a leader.
Whoops.
Okay, that makes sense.
I was like wondering like, what the fuck?
There's so much HP and so much like, uh...
Like so strong.
Alright, now I'm gonna kill the nerds.
Don't worry, it's nerd time.
Got the nerds now.
That's right, get over here.
Oh shit!
Oh my god, this nerd can fight back.
Wait, this nerd is also strong!
What the fuck?
Why are they feeding these- Bro, join an army!
What are you doing here?
This nerd is also so strong!
That's right, it's slowly heading towards you.
Oh fuck.
Oh my god, I'm barely doing any damage right now.
Nice.
Okay, one more move.
One more attack.
What the fuck?
Nice.
Parry this.
Okay, come on.
Just need one more hit.
Get over here!
Why are you running, nerd?
I have a locker!
Okay.
Get out!
Okay, one more.
One more guy to kill.
Alright, I had to...
Uh, a Judith?
The fuck does a Judith mean?
I don't know what Judith means- Oh my god, I did no damage to him.
At all.
It's okay.
That's fine.
The moment I get my Y move, it's over for you.
That's fucking right!
The most damage I'll do in this fight...
Is when I get to Y you.
And then do this too.
Nice.
Come on.
Oh my god.
I fucked up my parry.
God damn it.
It's fine.
Get out!
Oh my god!
We're gonna be bond level one after this!
We're gonna be past acquaintances, guys!
Yippee!
He's gonna see me as not an acquaintance after that, guys!
What's this?
Uh...
Yeah, let's get more...
Oh wait, I need to get...
I don't have enough, so I'll just update this.
Friendship!
I don't know why I did the thing.
That helps.
Oh, he gives me three dollars?
Our bond has grown stronger!
Oh my god!
Our bond has grown stronger, guys!
Maybe he sent a letter?
Oh, he didn't.
He didn't send me a letter.
Guys...
He didn't send me a letter, guys.
Oh!
Wait, he's back here!
Hello.
Of course, I'll try anything you want.
Oh.
Thanks.
Complaining?
I'll never complain.
Don't worry, I'll never complain.
There's nothing wrong with a quiet life of study...
I know, right?
There's nothing wrong with that.
Why are you judging him?
Yeah!
Stop moving, please.
Yeah,
let him farm!
STOP MOVING!
Using a farming manual?
Oh, you're so smart.
You're so smart.
You're so smart, Komi.
That's so true.
Aww.
I see.
He's...
He's satisfied!
He's enlightened!
Let him be a farmer!
Then he won't have to be disappointed in life for picking the wrong leader.
Oh, wait.
I don't want the mustache.
Oh, of course.
Of course, Pantone!
I will keep a lot of eyes on him.
Don't worry, he'll be safe under my guidance.
Don't you worry.
Goodness, to think both old friends and new acquaintances would show me such consideration.
NOOOOOOO!
Well then, guardian of peace...
He still sees me as an acquaintance!
NOOOOOOO!
After everything I've done, he doesn't see me as a friend!
I'm just an acquaintance to him!
Oh, it's the boy!
I'm not even a friend after everything I've done!
What's the point?
My
heart is broken.
I'll no longer feel anything anymore.
You got the acquaintance, though.
What's the point?
What's the point anymore?
I... I...
The one person I'm trying to chase...
Everybody else wants me...
But he doesn't even see me as a friend!
What's the point?
Calling it here...
He just wants to farm, don't he?
Just let him farm!
He's playing so hard to get!
Story as old as life!
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
Get strategized!
Thank you, Lucy for chatting!
Thank you, thank you!
As always, everybody, stay hydrated!
Posture check!
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing!
And if you stay up for me, head to bed!
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
I can't believe I got ejected!
Bye!